[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number 80 oh my god number 80 is
that possible
it's possible here we are here we are i
am dr brett weinstein this is dr heather
heing and i am going to emphasize those
degrees because today we are going to be
using them
both in terms of critically analyzing
important concepts
and as a defense against those who will
make accusations of us so
dr heather hines we are not we are not
trying to hide behind any false
credentials though we both have phds in
biology
that is right that's right um so
today uh we are going to talk about
uh some new developments in the loudly
hypothesis
we are going to talk about ivermectin
and we are going to talk about cicadas
and what combine what links all of those
i'm not sure i'm yet sure of that but
uh but but i'm sure we'll discover it
the glorious umbrella of evolutionary
biology
lets us talk about pretty much anything
we want so long as it moves
or develops or adapts it's pretty cool
yeah indeed um so we do encourage you
always at the top of the hour to
uh to subscribe to the channel go to the
clips channel subscribe to that
like the videos share with your friends
consider going to our patreons and
joining us there
uh we very much appreciate all the
support um this week
um for the first time in a few weeks we
also have an ad to go to so should we do
that
um should we do that next yeah let's pay
the rent okay
all right you want to start no i think
you should start
you have a prop for one thing well i'm
not no i don't um
okay so um this week we're going to talk
to you a little bit about public goods
uh public goods is a company uh that is
a
basically a one-stop shop for many of
your needs
uh a little bit like some other giant
vendors online that you might
imagine but they make all of their
products themselves
and uh the packaging is simple and
elegant and the products are
terrific uh we've tried their avocado
oil
and their chocolate-covered almonds and
both of those are delicious
and also shampoo and counter cleaner
and it all seems pretty good yeah the
stuff is high quality and the packaging
does not drive you crazy as you're
looking at somebody's idea of how to get
your attention in a market right these
are tasteful
understated they look nice they don't
they don't cause
a disruption of your thought as you run
into them in your life that's exactly
right they are they are understated as
you say and beautiful
and functional and um you know really
everything we haven't tried
the whole gamut of what they offer but
they sell coffee they sell pet food
they sell like we said shampoo
conditioner
so so many things
they also have a focus on organic
ingredients when when that's possible
and i guess maybe we should just finish
off by saying um that we can bring you
an awesome deal from uh for our
listeners you receive 15
off of your first public goods order
with no minimum purchase that's that
means obviously that you could
find something fifteen dollars and get
it for free um they
public goods is so confident that you
will love their products and come back
again and again that they are gonna give
you 15
to spend on your first purchase so you
have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com
um forward slash darkhorse or use code
darkhorse at checkout once again that is
p u b l i c g o o d s
dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive fifteen dollars
off your first order and we thank them
for sponsoring the dark horse podcast
all right don't pay on the rent
um all right should we start with do we
have announcements that we have not
covered we already did it
okay so let's start then with our first
topic which has to do with the lab leak
hypothesis and of course long time fans
of the dark horse podcast
will know that we have long discussed
the evidence
for the lab leak hypothesis and compared
it
to the evidence for what is treated as
the null hypothesis that this emerged
from nature
possibly through an intermediate species
but ultimately from
bats now there have been developments in
the last couple of weeks
in this story but they are not
scientific developments interestingly
enough
what they are is social developments
amongst scientists and those
who report on them so maybe we should
put up the letter that emerged
this week in science magazine it's on my
screen zach
and this um actually there's just one
paragraph that i think we can share
um to indicate what uh what is said here
if i may
uh it's called investigate the origins
of covet 19. it has
18 signatories in
including a number of notable people um
one of one of whom you will speak
speak to um quote
as scientists with relevant expertise we
agree with the who director general
the united states and 13 other countries
and the european union
that greater clarity about the origins
of this pandemic is necessary and
feasible to achieve
we must take hypotheses about both
natural and laboratory spill levers
seriously until we have sufficient data
a proper investigation should be
transparent objective
data-driven inclusive abroad expertise
subject to independent oversight
and responsibly managed to minimize the
impact of conflicts of interest
public health agencies and research
laboratories alike need to open their
records to the public
investigators should document the
veracity and provenance of data from
which analyses are conducted and
conclusions drawn
so that analyses are reproducible by
independent experts
yeah i only wish the letter ended with
the single word sentence
obviously right it is so clear that this
is a viable hypothesis and it should
have been investigated
seriously from the beginning rather than
dismissed as it has been
but what i want to do is put it in
context
so first thing to say is that the most
important thing about this letter is the
third author
the third author is ralph barrick and
ralph barrick
is the lead investigator the pi
in the unc lab that does
uh gain a function research on bat born
corona viruses it's one of the two
leading labs
in the world for this kind of work the
other one being at the wuhan institute
of virology the xi jiang li lab
and so to have one of two people
at the very forefront of this technology
come forward
and author a letter that says this is a
viable hypothesis and should be fully
investigated is to say
we have been right all along this was a
plausible hypothesis
from the beginning deserving of
scientific respect which is the opposite
of what it got what it got
was ridicule in fact in the leading
journal
um the lancet those
two medical journals the leading medical
journal the lancet i think jama's
probably i i don't know that the lance
is the leading medical team
a leading medical journal um one of two
prominent early publications dismissed
explicitly
as a conspiracy theory and those who
talked about it as conspiracy theorists
those
who were interested in looking into the
lab leak hypothesis
so to have ralph barrett come forward
and say in fact this is a viable
hypothesis and
deserves investigation is a
rare triumph where those who were
portrayed
as cranks at the outskirts who were
actually
correct and had the evidence with them
have been
in some sense vindicated now i do think
there's
as i've said before i don't like the
word vindicated here because what we all
need to be doing
all the time especially when we wear the
mantle of science
is looking for all possible explanations
and keeping all the possible
explanations alive
so long as they are not falsified well i
agree but when i say vindicated
so this letter if it is taken seriously
and if we don't see
funny business downstream of it which is
a possibility
we're already seeing a little bit but um
if this letter
is taken as the ground floor and now we
proceed from it as the letter suggests
that we should do
then the point is okay now we can begin
to compare the evidence fairly what has
been vindicated is those who said the
loudly hypothesis
is clearly viable and those who say
otherwise are
incorrect yeah it's it's a vindication
for the scientific method
and it's uh reveal once again that those
people who were saying you cannot
consider that were actually acting in an
anti-scientific way
absolutely and um if i may there is an
mit technology
technology review article if you would
show this sack
that came out in the wake of that
science letter and i just want to read
one
one paragraph from it from it the chief
scientist for emerging disease at the
woohoon institute of virology
xizeng xi jiang li said in an email that
the letter's suspicions were misplaced
and would damage the world's ability to
respond to pandemics
quote it's definitely not acceptable she
said of the group's call to see her
lab's records
who can provide an evidence that does
not exist
it's a very interesting statement um but
i would point out that one of the
really important things about this
letter and you know it isn't just ralph
barrett but the fact that he shows up
there
is the jaw-dropping fact of it the fact
that it has a lot of top people
including quite a number of people whose
specialty is evolutionary which i think
is actually
also an indication uh that you and i
have been on the right track here that
the evidence
that compels people to get uh out in
front here
is is largely evolutionary um but
the um where was i headed
damn i don't know i'll get it back in a
second okay um
so oh i know what it is the fact of
ralph barrack showing up
in mid-may saying lab leak hypothesis
is viable covers all of the various
things that were already on the table
that means
it is viable in spite of denials from
the xi jiang li lab this is a colleague
of
zhang li this is a sometimes
collaborator who is saying
not only he is implying by
showing up here he is implying that not
only is
sars cov2 as we find it consistent
at a technical at a molecular level with
techniques that might have been used
to enhance it in the lab right he is
saying
that the denials that he has heard are
not compelling to him
as a leading expert in the field one of
two top
labs in a position to know what is and
isn't possible what might or might not
have been done
so this is absolutely stunning to have
him emerge
and i will say he has said before he has
indicated
one cannot rule out lab leak but he has
done it uh
when pressed here he is coming out in
front and that's really important
and although i do think it's very late
and he should have done it much earlier
i'm glad to see him there
also worth noting he is co-author here
in fact the second author on this paper
paper is alina chan who is in my opinion
a great hero of this story because she
is
inside the academy has correct expertise
to speak
about uh molecular evidence and she's
early career which means this is
dangerous to her at a level that it
wouldn't be or would be much less so
if she were more advanced so to have
them co-authors on this paper is
significant
that's really good news it is really
good news and
i think she deserves our gratitude and
congratulations to her
on uh this letter published at this
level and that's the other
most important thing here is not only
do you have people of unimpeachable
credibility
saying that the lab leak hypothesis is
viable and deserves investigation
but you have them saying it in the
journal science
right now the journal science has
yes so unlike the lancet about which i'm
just not as sure
science and nature are are understood to
be you know whether or not these
reputations are still founded but
are understood to be the two most
important and prestigious science
journals
in the world yes and
important because science exists uh
as the sort of other side of the
um the duality that is science and
nature
right so science journals the journal
science and the journal nature right the
journal nature is a british journal
that is the other top journal and you
might add
cell if we were talking about molecular
biology but for general science
you've got science in nature and nature
was the place where
the christian anderson letter was
published at the beginning
of the pandit pandemic claiming i don't
know where that came
candy i don't think pandit is a thing
and i'm pretty sure it has nothing to do
with pandemics but
yeah anyway christian anderson published
uh
a letter early on claiming molecular
expertise that actually ruled out the
possibility that this was a lab leak
which is obvious nonsense and has been
obvious nonsense to everyone who has
looked at it
uh carefully um without a bias
but in any case now so to the degree
that there were wagons being circled
it seems that uh ralph barrick at least
was either not inside the circle or
has left the circle well you know
i also i don't think we're likely to
ever know
exactly why we won this one
but we did win this one win in this case
means keeping the hypothesis
alive until has actually been assessed
yep i am not claiming that we know the
answer here though i think
one answer is much more likely than the
other is i've said repeatedly
but there aren't just two hypotheses on
the table it's there's not a one or the
other there are multiple
possibilities there are two broad
classes and so
the particular details will be
interesting either way but but in any
case
um i don't think we will ever fully know
why this went
so differently than other cases where uh
whistleblowers and analysts try to
force recognition of an obvious truth in
general that's a failure yeah the powers
that be when they have
a desire to advance one story and hide
another are typically very successful at
doing it especially
when they have all of the important
properties i mean think about who it is
who has lined up against
investigating the lovely hypothesis it's
all the major tech
platforms it's major mainstream
newspapers
it's the academy right it's you know
up until now the major science journals
right that's an incredible arsenal and
to have
you know the outsiders the dark horses
right
um actually successfully force
recognition
of something uh that actually puts all
of those forces back on their heels is
amazing
why it happened it's a little hard to
say but part of the answer is
those who were on the other side were
very careful right many were highly
qualified
and there was a lot of courage and
because of that i think
somebody like ralph barrack he's a smart
guy and i think
he is sure to recognize this isn't going
away
and so anyway he you know i i'm glad he
has arrived at
at the conclusion he's apparently
arrived at and i'm glad that the journal
nature
i mean science um was uh willing to
publish this
i will say i have a couple of concerns
based on what i've seen so far
one concern is that there is an emphasis
in both
the letter that science published and
the blog
post that the editor who made the
decision apparently
posted about it which is there's an
emphasis on
the hazard that the lab leak hypothesis
might pose
to people of asian descent in other
words there's an emphasis
on that concern which i think frankly is
not
impossible that there would be such a
thing but i wonder if this is not an
indication of how this was rationalized
on the inside
that in effect people who knew better uh
were saying less than they understood
because they were attempting to protect
uh colleagues and others who
might legitimately fear a backlash
that's i guess that's possible i don't i
don't see this as emphasized in the
letter there is
you know the the very last very short
paragraph of a
admittedly short letter uh mentions um
that this should be in no way
an excuse to further anti-asian
sentiment which should be obvious to
every reasonable human being but
i don't i don't know that that qualifies
as an emphasis but perhaps
well it does in such a short letter it
does when it shows up also in the blog
commentary on the letter
um and then there is the fact of what
the new york times you know
still but but i guess i would say that
you know the scientists
the 18 scientists who wrote the letter
have no control at all over the blog
commentary on their research right like
they don't
i mean like we have to be very careful
about ascribing
any intention to the people writing the
letter for you know the
you know what goes on downstream because
that's part of that's part of what we've
been talking about right for over 14
months now is like
you know to the degree that scientists
are trying to get the word out
the media you know there's some there's
there seems to be some concerted effort
that may or may not be coordinated
um on the part of media and part of tech
companies on the part of
you know academia on the part of the who
various places
to to stop discussion and so you know
what happens
on a separately written post about a
letter
the authors of the original letter
cannot be held responsible no i'm not
holding them responsible but what i'm
saying is i think
given what in a very short pivot
is uh included and then mentioned again
in a commentary on the pivot
i'm wondering if this is not an
indication of the internal something
allowed lots of people who should have
known better to say things that didn't
make any sense
for more than a year so what is it that
they were saying to themselves is a
question that is very important if we're
to ever
face such a thing again and prevent it
from happening right
um so what was the internal excuse
that's a good question
and this may or may not be it or it may
or may not be part of it
but the other thing is well i mean
that's actually it's it's huge if that
is
if that is the case and i you know i i'm
not
i wouldn't put the possibility of that
very high myself but um what that
suggests
is that um fear of racism
has created an anti-scientific
movement that has clouded the waters
effectively for an entire year during
which the world has been in
unprecedented territories
across every domain right right and um
you know to to to which then i will
point my finger
at yes there are some actual racists out
there who are [ __ ] and need to
stop it right um but what we have
for almost exactly that same time period
and of course starting well be
before that is a focus on how racist
everyone is
right you know this this talk about how
everyone has to admit their own racism
um no doubt encourages the sense
that what we really need to do one of
the priorities we need to engage in
is making sure that no racism ever
happens and we do need to make sure of
that
but if there is a basically a false
boogeyman
wherein racism is misunderstood to be
far more widespread than it actually is
which
we have talked about extensively on this
podcast we understand that to be the
case
then if that is partially to blame for
this misdirect this this this just this
terrible policy and apparent you know
scientific backing of bad policy to
not engage what was obviously a possible
hypothesis from the beginning
then that's one more thing on the
list of harms that critical race theory
and intersectionality and locusm have
brought to the world exactly
agreed now the question though is how
does it fit with respect to a pivot that
has another
frightening feature to it okay so on the
one hand you've got this emphasis
on preventing a backlash against asians
which of course
makes sense but certainly if if this did
come from the wave it wasn't the chinese
people well but that that's that's been
my point
which is in fact those of us who have
been pushing for a responsible
investigation
of the lab leak have been saying this
isn't a chinese failure this is a
failure of the international scientific
community if that's where this came from
so we've been careful about that and to
now have a sort of
well we need to investigate this but
when it's like well actually we were
ahead on that too right
not the chinese this is not a chinese
failure now it may well the cover-up is
a failure of the chinese communist party
and the government of china but that's
not the same thing as the responsibility
of asians
right of course not and you know as as
you began this
this commentary by saying the wuhan
institute of virology and the barrick
lab in north carolina are actually the
you know by many measures the two most
premier labs in the world doing exactly
the kind of gain of function research
that would have allowed such a virus
potentially to be created
such that um you know this this kind of
research
needs to needs to be regardless of
whether or not this particular virus
emerged from a lab uh that this type of
research needs to be reassessed as it
was as i don't remember the dates we've
talked about it before
it was halted i think something like
2014 under the obama administration
um and reinstated in 2018 with the help
of dr fauci yes
during the trump administration but with
the help of dr fauci this type of
research was reinstated yep
and you know getting to the bottom of
this is central because
either this thing jumped from nature and
the people who were
screaming that we needed to do gain of
function research in order to get ahead
of the next pandemic
you know have been vindicated themselves
in a sense
right i don't think gain of function
research is sensible but if this
pandemic
really leapt from nature without going
through a lab then it tells one story
and if it came from the lab it tells the
opposite story that it was exactly
the panicked response to the possibility
of something jumping from nature that
caused us to put ourselves
in such a serious situation so i just
want to go to the
last thing on this is the new york times
article in which it attempts to
contextualize this letter in science
all right so zach you have that letter
can you put it i mean that uh
article so the new york times
basically does a report on the
uh the letter that includes uh barrick
and unfortunately i can't read it at
that size but
in any case it does a number of things
and effectively it reads like in it so
it's
uh carl zimmer is one of the authors it
reads as an attempt to
reposition the elite so that they don't
lose all credibility having been on the
wrong side of this issue
for so long with so much at stake and
so one of the things it does can you
scroll down a little bit more
so first of all it embarrassingly
conflates theory and hypothesis
again for no particularly good reason
uh okay so well
i can't i i'm not gonna be able to find
it with zach scrolling but what it says
in the center of this article is that
the problem in large measure is that
those
who have been uh pushing to
consider the lab leak hypothesis have
been expressing too much certainty and
that the problem
is people who have been too certain
right and it puts the
it's our fault yeah exactly it's our
fault even though
we haven't been certain we haven't been
certain at all in fact
uh i've been saying you know pivot right
there it's a clever pivot right and my
point has been
stop saying theory it's not a theory
it's a hypothesis
as is the other we are not certain here
are the ru you know when you say
it's a hypothesis you're saying here are
the exact rules of engagement well
what's going to come back at you
is that you made a flow chart and you
said you know here and also on bill
maher something like i think there's a
greater than 95
chance well and that is red um
apparently as
certainty well i don't know i think the
point is
those who are making this want to make a
general explanation of why they were on
the wrong
side right and to portray basically to
straw men anyone who was on the other
side
even though i think the strength of
those you know in the drastic group
uh of alina chan of us has been that
we've been very very careful to say
this isn't certain but there is an
impressive amount of evidence that
points in this direction
um and well i mean it's it's it's
typical now right like there there is
there is no end of attempts to further
divide us and you know they're
every kind of argument seems to be
rather than scientific and us versus
them argument
and the us versus them arguments of
course they sometimes clogged in
pseudoscience
some sometimes come cloaked in
pseudoscientific rhetoric
as if as if by going forward
with that you know yummy dopamine hit
feeling of i don't like the people who
look like that
i don't like the people who aren't
wearing masks outside i don't like the
people who think that the la the
this was a lab leak um as if that is has
anything to do with the scientific
assessment
of of any of these things that's a
that's a pure raw emotional like
amygdala um response that is not in any
way scientific
right and at some level here we have
um the hazard that as the elites often
do when they are unable to control a
story
they are going to do everything in their
power to not allow the implications of
it to be understood
the implications are something is wrong
with our institutional structure
that it got this one so very wrong and
that
forces us to ask the question what else
might it be getting wrong
so we can leave it at that but uh i
very much want people to keep an eye on
what was actually said
and uh what this pivot is going to do in
terms of portraying what was being said
okay so um
i'm not sure what to do i thought we
were only going to spend like two
minutes on that story and it took half
of our time
so maybe we should drop some of what we
were going to talk about with regard to
ivermectin um i have a lot prepared here
and i just don't think we really have
time to get through it all
wow so let's just let's just start and
see we can't just start we have we have
to talk about the predicament that we
are in on youtube with respect to
ivermectin which is mentioned
specifically in
uh their community guidelines
youtube has community guidelines you
really want to start before you even say
what the thing is
yeah i do because um
we are scientists who are about to talk
about scientific evidence
that scientific evidence may have
implications for
what we collectively ought to be doing
and what you individually might think
we are not going to make any
recommendations as to what you should do
and we are not going to say anything
conclusive about what the data say
because the data are not themselves
conclusive
however it doesn't mean the data don't
imply things and
you know i think youtube ought to think
very carefully about whether it wants to
confront
two people who have the proper
credentials
have demonstrated a willingness to be
responsible about evaluating heterodox
scientific
processes and in this case
are have just been through a
circumstance where
a hypothesis that they were suggesting
needed to be investigated is now
understood to be
necessary to be investigated uh you know
in science
etc so that's the context
okay so uh we have we've mentioned
ivermectin before
ivermectin uh became
somewhat prominent uh as something that
people were talking about early in the
pandemic probably
april may of last year people were
beginning to talk about it
um we spent considerable time actually
in episode 61
january 2nd of this year of 2021 in
which
we provided a bit of background as to
what it is
it was discovered by a scientist in 1975
in a patch of japanese soil satoshi
omura
called it astonishingly safe and a
wonder drug akin to penicillin and
aspirin
and a review in the journal of drugs and
dermatology concluded after more than 25
years
of use ivermectin continues to provide a
high margin of safety
now that was obviously um you know that
had nothing to do with efficacy against
cope and in fact the quote doesn't have
anything to say about efficacy
but but safety so um this is this is a
drug that has been
widespread uh in use for various
uh various pathogens um in both human
and non-human populations
um and veterinary applications for for
decades
at this point almost you know coming up
on or actually maybe at this point
50 years um no not quite i think it's
over 40 over 40 years
um and there have been a few people
sounding the gong
during the pandemic about whether or not
ivermectin
might be effective we know it to be safe
in humans from all of these studies that
have been done already because it's such
a widespread
drug in such widespread use whether it
might not be effective
either as treatment or as prophylaxis um
against tsar's cov2 prophylaxis i'm
never sure people know exactly what that
means if they are only associating the
word with condoms so
prophylaxis just means a preventative so
for instance we don't have a malaria
vaccine yet
so when you travel to malarial areas you
have to take prophylaxis of
one sort of the other depending on what
species of malaria is there if you've
got vivax or
plasmodium anyway sorry there are a
couple things i want to add to that
yep first of all um satoshi omura
shared the nobel prize with william
campbell for the discovery
of uh of this drug and
it has been in use um preventing
river blindness and treating river
blindness for all of these decades now
when we say it is safe
what we are saying is it is
comparatively safe
all drugs have downsides yes this one
has some downsides
in terms of what has been observed the
downsides are
short-lived in general and minor and
largely a result
of the death of the parasites that this
is used to fight in other words if you
are infected with a worm a parasitic
worm
and then that worm dies your immune
system actually has to take it apart at
a molecular level which may cause you to
itch and other things but that is part
and parcel of being cured of the disease
so
all drugs have downsides the downsides
on this one are very very low
yes absolutely when we first talked at
some length about ivermectin back in
early january of this year they were at
that moment
only three studies on ivermectin
proceeding in the u.s
none of them funded by nih or any other
u.s agency
which is which is at the very least
negligent
when when i go to the site now
the clinicaltrials.gov we find that
there are seven
two of which are not yet recruiting so
there are a few more than there were
um before but still really not that many
especially when you compare that to
um zach please may i see
my notes thank you um especially when
you compare that to
what we what we can now see in the
published literature
what is going on in the rest of the
world there are so many studies
um but without the full force of the
american government
um behind them that is to say that they
you know without nih backing without you
know without
without the incredible um
scientific establishment that the u.s
can bring to bear on on problems
why is the us government not um
not uh
i'm sorry you're trying to tell me
something and i'm not sure what it is
because i can't read your
writing i'm sorry um okay so there is a
review um car at all 2021.
oh no actually first uh we wanted to say
that
uh a new paper by sahad all
zack if you will published this year
submitted this year in fact and
published this year march 2021
the binding mechanism ivermectin and
levus albutamol with spike protein of
sars cov2
so that's all we need to show of that
we're not going to go into depth in any
of these papers but basically what this
paper
finds is the mechanism of action by
which ivermectin
might work against sarskv2
which is by binding to the spike protein
which
you know sure turns out to be you know
so prevalent in so many stories around
cyrus kobe 2 is the spike protein yeah
because the spike protein is essential
to getting into the cells
in order to do the bidding of the virus
blocking the cell protein is an obvious
go-to move which is why the vaccines
look the way they do
the distinction here though i would
point out is that ivermectin's
mode of action is loosely
analogous with innate immunity in other
words ivermectin was not constructed
in order to target the spike protein of
sars
it generally has an effect that gets in
between
the spike protein and the cells that it
might invade preventing the
mode of action which implies that the
chances of
sars kobe 2 evolving around it are much
reduced right because this is not a
specific thing that can be undone by
slight changes
it's a generalized activity right so
you've got a
comparatively safe drug we've got a
known mechanism of action which frankly
you don't even need but
there is one that's fascinating blocks
the activity of the spike protein
and it appears to do so in a way that is
unlikely to
be subject to small evolutionary changes
disrupting it
and i guess that's also a fit for how
many applications we
already know that are you know fda
approved for ivermectin there's so many
different pathogens
that ivermectin seems to be effective
against
um that it working as a is kind of a
broad spectrum
um i don't even know it's you know
antiviral in this case but
anti-pathogenic anti-pathogenic yeah and
i don't you know i don't think
broad-spectrum anti-pathogen is a term
of
a weird category right um but it you
know it seems to be that
um so there's a also a review this is um
car at all don't show my screen yet zack
um
ivermectin is a potential drug for
treatment of cope at 19 and in sync
review with clinical and computational
attributes
this is also published um the 3rd of
january this year
and a couple of you know
they basically are just these these guys
are reviewing other people's research
and most of the studies are small you
know the n is small
in almost all of these studies because
there are no giant clinical trials um
that that i have seen yet they say
another study by a lambda reported that
ivermectin and doxycycline's combination
is very efficacious and sars cov2
clearance in patients with mild to
moderate disease
later they say according to the results
of another paper
which we'll link to all of these
ivermectin combined with doxycycline was
safe and efficacious in early viral
clearance in patients
um and took less time than uh in this
other paper they were comparing it to
hydroxychloroquine and azithromycin
combination for viral clearance
uh and actually you can uh
zach just show nope not yet uh where
is it and
oh here it is so they just i'm not gonna
walk through this whole table but they
they run through the summary of um
the papers that were available to them
that they reviewed and in all of
all of the cases um where they were
there was a
uh ivermectin being compared to some
other treatment ivermectin was doing as
well but usually
much better so um
so let me pause this there so you will
see
frequently in the discussion of why we
mustn't
think about talk about ivermectin you
will see the claim
that uh there are no large-scale
studies that would give us the evidence
what there is
is meta-analysis that actually looks at
many studies as you've just described
and that is in fact a better kind of
evidence right
so it would be nice if we had a really
large
long-standing study but a meta-analysis
that gives you
a consistent indication is the
equivalent or more
of a large study a large study can be
biased
a meta-analysis the biases of various
different
researchers will tend to be cancelled by
the fact that they won't be consistent
between these things
the other thing to say is large studies
are great because they reveal very small
uh effects when you have a very large
effect
you do not require a very large study to
see it and so
the uh the compilation of all of these
things
is very strongly suggestive that
ivermectin
does work and uh what we know about it
from the context in which it has been
used as an anti-parasitic
suggests it's very safe which then we
would have to put
in to juxtapose it to the alternatives
here
well i i'm not sure i totally agree with
all of that um i think
i you know i would point my finger at
nih and some of the you know the the
governmental agencies within the us who
are normally the ones who would help
make happen it would help facilitate the
large-scale studies you know it's
exactly
these organizations who are in part and
are their representatives who are saying
well we can't assess this because there
are no large-scale studies
exactly while um i think we are seeing
evidence that they may be helping
make sure that there are no large scale
studies so that you know that's
that's a problem right there um and then
we do also have
some evidence from africa of different
kind you know it's not a large it's not
a large-scale clinical study
um but basically going back in
afterwards and looking at results
having been having done a um
without imagining that's what they were
doing they effectively pulled an
experiment
on several populations within africa but
before we go there
um with regard to this cowardl review i
did want to just spend a moment talking
about the fact that many of the studies
they were reviewing
were combining ivermectin with doxy with
doxycycline which is an antibiotic
and um sometimes the the so-called
control group the other group was
hydroxychloroquine uh with uh
azithromycin zithromax which is another
antibiotic and this this struck me as
surprising i'm not i'm not sure why
we are expecting these these drugs that
are understood to be antibacterials
to be effective against a virus and
this seems to go against a um you know
one of the few
things uh that we learn in sort of basic
biology
about um about drug efficacy
and you know how you know doctors should
never be prescribing
antibiotics when what you've got is a
virus you know what you've got is a cold
right
um so there's this again just like we're
in complex system space
and somehow ivermectin in combination
with doxy with doxycycline might
actually
be even more effective i'm
i'm worried about widespread use of
doxycycline and you know it's also
effective as an anti-malarial actually
and but it is uh it has
known effects uh with regard to sun
exposure
and so you know when you're on
doxycycline you're really not supposed
to be spending time in the sun because
you're much more prone to burning and of
course we also know that spending time
in the sun is good for you with regard
to
um defending yourself uh defending your
body defending itself against stars kobe
2. so
there are a lot of things to juggle here
so let's let's sort that a little bit
okay
one it is interesting that in the case
of things that are not
bacteriological or fungal that we see
increasingly that antibiotics which we
have been told
are should be limited to the use against
fungi and bacteria turn out to be useful
so this is a welcome to complex systems
phenomenon hey you're getting surprised
by something that you didn't uh think to
predict
b that's not to say that it makes any
sense at all for a doctor to prescribe
an antibiotic when you do come in
with a virus who's to say what effects
what and see
we also learned back you know decades
ago
about how safe these antibiotics tended
to be and that turns out to be
wrong right these things have uh
downsides because of course welcome to
complex systems so
you know what landscape are we in pretty
hard to know whether the nih
is integral to why the big studies don't
exist
maybe but i think the point is you
somehow at the root of all of this is
some
weird license with no limit to a double
standard
right so if some if the for powers that
be
decide they don't like something like
ivermectin they can
establish any standard up to a
ridiculous degree that nothing can
overcome right when it comes to the
thing that they
favor there's almost no standard at all
right there's no level of danger
that could be sufficient to call it into
question and so
we don't know what that looks like on
the inside but what you can see
is the hallmark of it is a double
standard that is glaring if you know how
to analyze what's being said
absolutely so when we began to really be
thinking a lot about
ivermectin again a week ago or so i said
to you i wonder if
given how widespread and given how many
decades ivermectin has been used
um to to decrease uh
you know pathogens uh in africa in
particular if that may not be playing a
role in why we
why many african nations seem to be
doing much better than you might
otherwise expect
um and that you know there are other
reasons um to there are other
possibilities of course
um but we actually we found two papers
this week and
i imagine there might be more but we
found two papers uh
one of which is uh this one
zachary says hellwig and maya
titled it published in the international
journal of antimicrobial agents
titled the covet 19 prophylaxis question
mark lower incidents associated with
prophylactic administration of
ivermectin
so in that paper
they have um
boy would it be useful if i had
i can't i can't do it um so their
methods um
the methods in this paper are we
collected data from countries that
routinely deploy prophylactic
chemotherapy that's pct
using countries that um i'm going to
start again
their methods are as follows and i'm
quoting them we collected data from
countries that routinely deploy
prophylactic chemotherapy
using various drugs including ivermectin
based on the various
varying mda designs we group these
countries into two different categories
those that include ivermectin
in their prophylactic chemotherapy and
those that do not
we then proceeded to compare covet 19
proliferation between these two groups
and further contrasted them against a
third group of countries that do not use
prophylactic chemotherapy
at all so they've got three groups
they're comparing
um groups that simply use prophylactic
chemotherapy because of all of the other
things that are in you know that are
endemic in these countries
river blindness like river blindness and
of those countries in africa that use
prophylactic chemotherapy there
are two sets one of which has
hypermectin and the prophylaxis and one
of which doesn't and then there are
countries that don't use prophylactic
chemotherapy at all and here uh
zach is figure three from this paper
which shows
for those just listening on the y-axis
we have incidents cases per
100 000 um people and the three
categories
on the left we have prophylactic
chemotherapy
that includes ivermectin a short squat
image because there are a lot of
countries and they're they have very low
incidence rates
in the middle we have countries that use
prophylactic chemotherapy but don't that
those don't include ivermectin
and then we have a lot of and there
aren't very many countries in that group
most of the countries in africa that use
prophylactic chemotherapy include
ivermectin
in their uh chemotherapy treatment and
then we have a number of countries in
africa
on the right um that use no prophylactic
chemotherapy at all and so the authors
go to great lengths to say look we know
that the sample sizes are way different
and um and and this is coming in
after the fact and all of this but look
at these numbers
the countries that were already
deploying ivermectin at the population
level
have far lower case case counts
case rates um than the countries uh that
are either deploying chemotherapy
um again chemotherapy meaning something
different
chemical therapy yeah um without
ivermectin or none at all
right so that's that is a very
interesting piece of data
um thank you zac so i just said this is
this is effectively
a natural experiment right so
things vary between islands this is
countries vary in what they've been
doing and we can now look at the
difference between those countries and
it is a profound
difference which we can't say for
certain comes from this but and here's
just the other study that does very much
the same thing okay
this is um guerrero at all published
again this year
in um this is a colombian medical
journal covet 19 the ivermectin african
enigma it is called
so i'm going to take my screen back
please thank you
so that we can show you
um this
this is the paper just in pdf format
they under their remarks they have three
what do these results contribute
our data suggests that a mass public
health preventive campaign against covet
19 may have taken place
inadvertently in some african countries
with massive community ivermectin use
additional studies are needed to confirm
it so that
they come to really the same conclusion
as that first study but there's two of
them not working together who
looked at very similar data probably
basically the same data and came up with
the same answer
so our viewers ought to be considering
this question
in light of conspicuous patterns like
that
and in light of the fact that the drug
in question
has a very long extreme
safety record why wouldn't you test it
right why wouldn't you do that large
scale study why wouldn't you
deploy it somewhere to see whether it
had the effect
and then discover whether or not this
was
uh you know i mean i don't think we've
said this time
but this appears to be uh effective
in controlling covid from people who've
already contracted it and preventing
contraction
right treatment and prophylaxis
treatment and prophylaxis if you imagine
the thing blocks the spike protein
that's integral to how it gets between
people
it's also integral to how it gets
between cells right
so this is highly effective in both
cases it would appear
so what on earth is the excuse for not
testing this
well unfortunately i think i may have at
least part of an answer
um but but one more thing before we go
to that so if you can
pose that question once more in just a
minute
um let us just point out this is a paper
from
pre-coven remember those days i do
yeah i do too um what's called
an observational study um published in
2019
in the british journal of dermatology it
looks like i think that's what that's
going to stand for
called ivermectin safety and infants and
children under 15 kilograms treated for
scabies a multicentric observational
study
so this has nothing to do with covet at
all this is simply
um and it's nothing to do with efficacy
actually even like i think
from from what i can infer from this
paper efficacy in ivermectin against
scabies had already been established but
now they were looking at look can we
actually give it to really tiny kids can
we give it to infants and kids under 15
kilograms which is like 13 pound
uh 13. about 33 pounds uh and
what they find um is that um is
is yes they find you know obviously
there are always risks but
this is a remarkably
a remarkably safe drug uh for something
that has such broad scale
efficacy and remarkably safe in this
case means short-term
and as far as we can tell long term
because it's been in use
so long exactly okay so
um what was the question you just asked
the question is
given all of the evidence circumstantial
inadvertent experiment as it may be from
all of the evidence that this appears to
have a mechanism for action
and appears efficacious in preventing
both the spread between people and the
spread within a person
why on earth would you not run
a very large study that would tell you
for sure
how good this was and how best to use it
yeah why wouldn't you why wouldn't you
and uh
wouldn't it wouldn't it be a legitimate
word to use that it would be criminal if
you didn't
if you knew that it would be a good idea
to do so
well as it turns out if ivermectin were
an effective treatment
the vaccines never would have gotten
emergency use authorization in the us
and um we know that um
because even though even my computer
would like me not to be talking about
this
here is and we'll link we'll link to uh
the
url for this but here uh here is just a
downloaded
uh version of the document from the fda
emergency use authorization of medical
products and related authorities
guidance for industry and our state and
other stakeholders
so i'm going to scroll down this is from
january 2017
expires in 2022 this is still the um
the guiding document and you go down
not very far although it may seem like
it's going fairly far
um and find emergency use authorizations
where'd it go um
i swear it's here here we go criteria
for
issuance under emergency use
authorization medical products
one criteria for issuance there
are a few it needs to be a serious or
life-threatening disease or condition
there needs to be evidence of
effectiveness there needs to be a risk
benefit analysis
and d there need to be no alternatives i
quote for the fda to issue an emergency
use authorization there must be no
adequate approved and available
alternative to the candidate product for
diagnosing
preventing or treating the disease or
condition
a potential alternative product may be
considered unavailable if there are
insufficient supplies for the approved
alternative to fully meet the emergency
need
that is not a problem for ivermectin by
not
doing the relevant large-scale clinical
studies on ivermectin and thus it not
being
approved by the fda for use in kovid
that opens the door for euas for
emergency use authorization
for the vaccines that we are now all
living with and among this is
stunning if that is the explanation then
we are talking about
something for which i'm not even sure we
have a proper term
because anchor inducing
uh it is that but let's just say
um this would have
elements of malpractice
this would be gross
negligence i think it verges on
depraved indifference given that we're
talking about
a life or death situation for
vulnerable people who get this disease
in addition
to effectively the crippling of the
world economy and who knows how much
harm we'll never be able to measure all
the harm
that came from this pandemic and the way
it has forced us to alter our behavior
all the businesses that have closed all
the people have been rendered homeless
who's to say
what all of the costs actually are and
if there is this is effective if this is
effective and you know
we can't say that it is but we can say
look evidence works a certain way
this certainly seems like a whole lot of
evidence that points in a direction
and if it were just simply good at
treating people with covid
that would be immense the fact that it
appears
comparable in preventing people from
contracting the disease
to at a prophylactic dose at a
prophylactic dose two
vaccines that we happen to have
a long-standing administration of this
thing to people and in parts of the
world where there are things like river
blindness
people do take this regularly in fact i
think is referred to as sunday sunday
because
people remember to take it uh on a as a
weekly or bi-weekly basis
the point is we have a lot of
information on how people tolerate this
drug
so if it was a great drug for this that
would be
immensely good news for planet earth
what's more
this stuff is readily makable right
you can make this stuff all over the
world and in fact it is too readily
makable probably
too readily makable now what do you mean
by that well
it's been around for a very long time
and it's no longer under patent
no longer under patent so anybody can
make it and not violate uh and yet
and yet check out i mean you actually
sent me this so you know this but
check out mark's response uh so merck
does merck does not like ivermectin at
all
i want to point out the the history here
so
satoshi is in here okay omura discovers
this compound
he sends it to william campbell who i
think is a friend of
his who is a merc scientist okay right
ivermectin is the drug that emerges
it gets a nobel prize right
so those two or those two those
well those two got a nobel prize for
their discovery of that drug and they
shared that nobel prize
with a woman who was being heralded for
discoveries
in fighting malaria i believe but in any
case a nobel prize was awarded for the
discovery of the compound
that became ivermectin which is a merck
drug
okay what does mark say mark says um
here actually maybe let's see if i can
show the relevant here we go okay so
this um
this is a quote from an article that i
will link to mark's patent on ivermectin
expired in 1996
and they produce less than five percent
of global supply in 2020 they were asked
to assist in nigerian and japanese
trials but declined both
in 2021 mark released a statement
claiming that ivermectin was not an
effective treatment against covet 19 and
bizarrely claimed quote
a concerning lack of safety data in the
majority of studies
of a drug they donated to be distributed
in mass rollouts by primary care workers
in mass campaigns to millions
developing countries the media reported
the mark statement as a blinding truth
without looking at the conflict of
interest when days later
merck received 356 million dollars from
the us government to develop an
investigational therapeutic
the who even quoted mark as evidence
that it didn't work in their
recommendation against the use of
hypermectin
it's a dangerous world when corporate
marketing determines public health
policy
global vaccine rollout to everyone is
the policy
so is there a polite way of saying what
the [ __ ] is going on
right yeah like we're talking about a
situation
in which life and limb
is on the line at a scale that's almost
impossible to comprehend we're talking
about
millions of dead worldwide this is an
immense number of people who stand to
benefit not to mention
all of the suffering that comes to
people who have lost a family member
right that is an immense immense amount
of harm
before you ever get to the massive
disruption of planet earth
right and it appears that there's
something
just on the shelf cheap to make
safe to distribute long longitudinal
safety data that comes from the fact
that millions of people take this thing
in fact i believe four billion doses of
this thing have been administered
already on planet earth it was plenty
safe for merck to distribute widely when
it was still under patent but now
they're claiming the safety record is
insufficient
right well that doesn't even make sense
that's what
before you get to the end of the
sentence you've already contradicted
yourself somehow
so yeah this is just something
ungodly is going on and the idea that
not only does it show
up in weird contortions of merck and
the who but it shows up in the youtube
community guidelines thou
shalt not right what is going on this is
insane
what what indeed what indeed um so i
will also post the
this murk statement on ivermectin use
the whole thing um on our show notes
it's not it's not easy reading it's not
it's not fun but
um i mean i guess we've already talked
about this
but media is all crickets on this on
ivermectin yeah
when they aren't actually saying that
there's no there's no possibility of
efficacy at all so we mentioned i
believe in episode 61
the ap having fact-checked uh ivermectin
and they concluded without basis that
quote there's no evidence that
ivermectin has been proven a safe or
effective treatment against covet-19
and indeed that same fact-checking
article um has
about safety and this is actually i
think i think
i can get there yeah okay um so this
this article no evidence ivermectin is a
miracle drug against covenant 19.
wait i have to stop you right there yeah
this the more you
read this article well i i have a quote
from it
crazier it is but i just want to point
out the title
no evidence that ivermectin is a miracle
drug
right when you're hyperbolic in the
second part of the sentence the fact
that you don't have any evidence that
this thing is
beyond yeah you know this is fact
checking
20 21 this is fact this is this is
hyperbole
garbage is what this is absolutely um so
the quote since i will not be able to
find it by scrolling down i'm just going
to read it here
uh in march an arizona couple attempted
to self-medicate
and took chloroquine phosphate an
additive used to clean fish tanks that
is also an ingredient hydroxychloroquine
the woman became gravely ill and the man
died
what pray tell does that have to do with
ivermectin that is in a fact checking
off
article by the associated press which is
then going to be referred to
by other media article supposedly about
ivermectin and its
failure to be a miracle drug uh iverman
because a couple of yahoos
um drink fish cleaner
which is not in any way related to
ivermectin like
that's that's that's a fact check that
out it's just like so many steps removed
right there
fat check is about ivermectin ivermectin
exists
in context of another drug that people
think might work and then some people
bought some stuff that they
thought was the the second drug and that
somehow
implies the first drug isn't any good
yeah it's not eve i mean we've talked
about this but it's not even guilt by
association for drugs it's like guilt by
association for
drugs and i i don't even know what and
actually
i think when we talked about this before
it was two episodes ago episode 78
um i quoted from um washington post
article on april 8th
and i'm just going to read this quote
again again i'll put the link again in
the show notes
um with regard to ivor mektin quote it's
like the new hydroxychloroquine said
angela rasmussen a virologist at
georgetown university's center for
global health science and security
referring to the malaria drug published
pushed by president donald trump that
proved ineffective against kova 19.
quote it would be great if ivermectin
did work it's been around for years and
is cheap
but to my knowledge there is no data
that suggests it's good for kova 19.
and of course that's just thinly veiled
code for this thing smells like trump
and if it smells like trump it must be
bad so good people not just cam but
indeed
should must safely ignore this thing and
it's probably better if you mock and
deride anyone who takes this
seriously as well yeah right like just
like just sort of
wave your arm the general direction of
like an orange halo over there and
imagine it's trump and put anything you
don't like next to it
and boom your problem is gone right but
the problem is that this stuff
carries like the weight of law
right if we can't talk about it on
youtube right
because it violates the who guidelines
but of course the who
is out of control for reasons that we
can speculate on but have no way of
knowing
and you know that fact-checking article
i remember there's also a sentence in
the middle of it that actually says
what the thing means like the actual
fact
and the critique like the the actual
critique is something like
the studies that suggest that ivermectin
is
effective are not the gold
standard blah blah blah blah blah and
the point is well that's not an
argument at all yes it is an argument
that you might want
you know a study that didn't have the
defects of the ones that exist but
that's hardly the same thing as there's
no evidence for it there is evidence for
it even if
every effort has been made to leave the
impression that it hasn't so that people
who have the power to shut up those who
would talk about the evidence will do
that
right and in whose interest might they
be doing that
it's hard to come up with another
candidate right
right then the people who stand to make
a profit
from other treatments whether it's rem
de severe
or vaccines and
the really appalling thing here
is if the world is to get over covet 19
having botched the response to this
point
right our best hope is
some kind of composite herd immunity
where there are not enough people
susceptible
to this disease for the disease to
continue to propagate and then
it goes extinct over time how are you
going to get there
well who's not susceptible people who've
had covid have at least some immunity
for some time right and it may be a lot
of immunity and it may be for a very
long time
we can say the same thing about people
who've had the vaccine it looks to be a
very comparable
you know for if if the vaccines are
going to require you annual boosters
then the amount of time that uh your
naturally achieved immunity from
exposure to actual stars kobe 2
and the amount of immunity that you
receive that you get from being
vaccinated
might well be comparable and are appear
really unfortunately not to be permanent
right yeah okay so you've got those two
categories
right and then you might have another
category if ivermectin works
and you administer it widely which you
could do very very quickly because of
course it can be produced by anybody it
is already being produced
around the world for other reasons right
you ratchet up
that uh campaign you give it to people
that provides a third
group that would be very uh would have
a high degree of immunity to contracting
the disease
if you can get that kind of have you run
into anything sorry to interrupt but um
have you run into anything i just have
not seen this and i i think the question
hasn't been asked
but whether or not if you were on a
prophylactic dose of ivermectin
um it would do anything to reduce if you
were exposed to sars cov2
you are better able to def it's the
evidence suggests that you are better
able to defend yourself against it
but are you able to spread it yourself
do you do you remain contagious yourself
this is a big issue with the vaccines
right there seem
you know because you can be asymptomatic
with a vaccine you might be more likely
to spread it
because you might be being less careful
because you think you're immune to it
and i don't know i have not seen any
evidence of this with regard to
ivermectin
well um i i would point people
to um to pierre
corey's group they have a lot of
information on the web i recall there's
a very interesting study i believe it
was argentina
in which a lot of frontline workers it
was like 1200 frontline workers
were part of a a study 800 of them got
ivermectin 400 of them didn't not a
single one
in the 800 contracted the disease
and quite a number did in the other
group yeah more than 50
did in the in the other group um but
what that doesn't say is if any of those
800 who were treated with ivermectin
prophylactically
um still were able to
you know if they were exposed spread the
disease to anyone else
i would like to know that i would like
to know it too but let's just say
if loosely speaking based on what we've
seen if the numbers are anything
like they appear to be then the
composite
of people who have a prophylactic uh
relationship with ivermectin
people who've had covid and therefore
have immunity for some time
most of them people who've had the
vaccine and therefore have immunity for
some time
most of them um that composite group
could well be quickly above the number
that creates herd immunity where kovid
starts becoming less common because it
can't find a willing victim
yeah so
what would it take if you knew that that
was the case to block
that effort wouldn't it be much more
likely to get to 80 percent
of any given population compliant with
one of those three
things one of those three categories
right rather than saying
there's one and only one road uh to
being a good person in this game in this
era
um you know the vaccines
seem to be effective they simply cannot
have the safety record that ivermectin
does
ivermectin without giant scale clinical
studies seems to be effective and does
have
decades-long safety record it does and
you know i feel weird about this because
you know
we are oddly at the epicenter for
various reasons
i think primarily because uh we are
in a position to have fears that are
backed by
uh scientific training right our
concerns about the vaccines
are founded the hazard of vaccines for
which we have no long-term data
that interact with the immune system in
a novel way right
those hazards are real whatever the
long-term harms actually turn out to be
the fact that we don't know what they
are at this point
is a legitimate reason for us not to
want to be vaccinated
right in light of that in light of the
fact that anybody who follows that same
trail of logic might reasonably end up
in that same category not because
they're anti-vaccine
as we have said many times we're as
vaccinated as anyone we are
highly pro-vaccine in this case we are
concerned about we don't what we don't
know about
these vaccines and that is not a wild
guess
that is on the basis of our best
understanding and the huge unknowns that
exist surrounding this technology so why
wouldn't
you want to investigate whether or not
people who are concerned
about the hazard of these vaccines for
themselves and their families
might have an alternative that is
approximately as
effective at fending off covid right if
your real interest in wagging your
finger at everybody
about masks and vaccines is to get us to
a position
where covet can't spread anymore then
shouldn't you want to provide
the maximum diversity of useful
technologies that people can deploy
so the sum total of us really are immune
to this disease at a level that it then
goes extinct and we can stop
living this way i do i mean what
reasonable person wouldn't
yeah what reasonable person wouldn't if
they were actually
if they actually cared about the things
they say they care about if they're
actually interested
in the health of humanity and the
societies that we live in
um i guess the other thing just to
connect two of the dots here
um that maybe should be obvious is
we potentially have a problem with
schools as these as some of the new
variants
um seem to be more willing to infect
children
and uh i don't know if it's the fda or
whoever just approved
uh one's the pfizer vaccine for 12 to 15
year olds
but there's a lot of people who are
adults and are willing to take
one of the mrna vaccines they're not
willing to let their kids anywhere near
it
and certainly we want to protect our
children um from
from them as well because the risks are
higher for younger people for
two broad reasons they are still
developing and so
there are often um often drugs that are
safe and adults are not safe for
children this is part of why you don't
drink when you're pregnant you don't
give alcohol to three-year-olds right
everyone knows this
and of course more of their life is
ahead of them yet so they have more time
to experience any long-term effects that
might result
so for those two reasons alone you want
to be much more cautious about giving
things to children
that are not vetted by long-term
research
but ivermectin
appears to be have a very long-term
safety record
even in very tiny children we still
don't have the giant clinical trials
with regard to efficacy against covid
but maybe especially given the problem
in schools
and especially given that variants may
be now figuring out how to leap into
kids because more and more the adult
population is vaccinated there's less
reservoir in the adult population
maybe ivermectin um to you know 18 year
olds and under
would be a legitimate way to start
rolling this out and you know maybe if
you really have to play your
damn games you can do it in such a way
that you know the the vaccines are only
for
over 18 year olds and the kids are for
the ivermectin is for
younger people but you know really why
why do you need to play those games
with all of our lives like that that's
that's the big question yeah that is the
big question and
you know the contrast to me between
getting us little folks to go after each
other over moral failings for being
frightened of novel vaccines and things
while the
the big people are apparently playing
business as usual
with you know not only the lives of
strangers
but um the normal business of planet
earth
right the fact is ivermectin isn't new
we could have been investigating this
all along if there needed to be a
campaign to ratchet up its production
it could be underway and if it turns out
that it's disappointing
i mean frankly if it was half as good as
it appears to be
it would be tremendous so you know if
it's as good as it appears to be
then how much did we lose dragging our
heels and on whose behalf and how many
people participated in shutting down
this discussion and why
right that just it's it's mind-boggling
to me it really looks like
crime of the century stuff and you know
hopefully sometimes century is still
young but it seems like a good contender
it does seem like
it's in the early lead right um
and you know it ought to among other
things the fact of uh
you know the long slow road to the
acknowledgement that lab leak is a
viable
answer to where this thing came from and
therefore we have to wonder about gain
of function research we should also then
be
wondering about the people who pushed it
you know
fauci peter dasik right
all of the things that got that in
motion we should now be questioning all
of the
newspapers that signed up for the
standard
line frankly the this week in virology
podcast this week
they were very instrumental in uh making
sure that no one
who took loudly seriously was taken
seriously early on
right and you know we've got entire
fields of biology the fields that we
most need which are apparently
compromised by some political
willingness to shut down discussions
they find inconvenient or threatening to
their future prospects or whatever so we
have to look at this now
as you know i sometimes say
certain stories diagnose the system
right you do
what happened to us at evergreen
diagnosed the system because the
mainstream press couldn't figure out
what to do with a story
in which you had people advocating
for uh for blacks who
were behaving in a bigoted way towards
whites it's not a natural story so they
either didn't report it or they reported
it upside down
right so that diagnosed the press
this story seems to diagnose a much
larger
phenomena diagnosis the tech sector it
diagnoses the press it diagnoses the
scientific establishment
it diagnoses the governmental regulatory
apparatus
all of those things and we have to take
a good long look at what happened
because oh my god the cost could hardly
be bigger
yeah and i guess it also diagnosis you
already mentioned um
pierre corey who you know if you've been
paying any attention to the
ivermectin story at all you'll be
familiar with his name
he's an md who is a lung specialist
who's treated a lot of codes
patients and um he testified before the
senate in
i guess it was late last year i think um
and that was taken down
by by youtube by youtube
senate testimony by a doctor who's
treating covet patients who's
found that this drug ivermectin appears
to be helping
and asking for authorization to use it
on label instead of off label
youtube takes it down not only that
we're talking about not just a doctor
we're talking about a highly decorated
doctor who had
already improved our treatment of
covid19
by discovering the use of
corticosteroids against
sick against the pathology okay this is
somebody who had
already earned the right to say
heterodox things many times over
right and yet youtube takes it down
testament even if he was a crank
testifying to congress people have a
right to see that
but the fact is this wasn't the crank if
the senate has decided to invite someone
to testify where does youtube get off
where do they get off yeah they took
that down
and yet dr fauci claiming that we didn't
support
gain of function research is somehow you
know
normal like that's an obvious lie it
obviously involves defining things in
some
secret way that nobody's going to tell
us right
that's nonsense right so we'll post this
but you can just briefly put up
uh zach back in february of 2021 there
was actually an op-ed in the wall street
journal called youtube cancels the us
senate
uh written by uh ron johnson who's a
senator from wisconsin
um so he details some of what we just
were talking about ron johnson
well apparently in the state of
wisconsin
oh my gosh you work in a lumber yard
there
all right we should we should have
looked him up it's just a question
yeah i i get you all right oh i didn't
want to cry just work here
the reason we don't give alcohol to
three-year-olds
there are a couple reasons one is the
medical reason that you point to but the
other is they don't know their limits
no they really don't they really don't
no oh okay
can we talk about cicadas uh yeah are
you oh
no no you got something else yeah i do
have something else and i
you know i have some regulations about
it but um here's the thing
i feel endangered because we have not
been vaccinated because we have fears as
we have discussed
at length on this podcast and
my sense is that given what i have read
i am not recommending this to anybody
else in fact i'm not even going to
recommend it to you but you've seen what
i've seen you can make your own decision
um but given the apparent effectiveness
of ivermectin
at preventing covid given the fact that
we are not vaccinated and therefore are
more vulnerable to contracting it
um i feel like i mean i should also
point out that the dosages which you can
find
on uh the consortium that
19 critical care alliance the flccc
which we'll also link to
right they have all of this evidence and
they also have a protocol document about
how you how you might use our vermectin
uh if
you haven't been confronted with covid
if you think you've been exposed and
the patie the treatment of patients and
so anyway the guidelines are fairly
simple um and so anyway i feel like i
should be on it because as much as no
drug is perfectly safe
i feel the danger of covet in the world
is much greater than the danger that
comes from taking
this stuff which among other things
very cheap but it's also it doesn't have
to be taken frequently you take it
two doses 48 hours apart and then i
think it's weekly
so anyway uh i think cost benefit for me
it makes sense to to go on it sounds
similar to a prophylactic dosage regime
for
most of the anti-malarial drugs yeah
exactly
so um which you know for those you
wouldn't want to be on forever
but you know we used to spend a long
long you know many months at a time
in places where malaria was endemic and
we're on malaria prophylaxis and
yeah that stuff
so how many that looks like a large dose
you're no it's not well
i'm i'm splitting this because my dose
and your dose
are these are six milligram
actually i should
there is no telling i want to use the
same standard of safety that the ap
uses and the fact is if i split one of
these pills
anything could happen it could explode
into shards that could uh destroy every
i mean frankly so for those listening at
home he's got safety glasses on now i
have safety glasses on
because you're looking at the world
through safety colored glasses i am
all right okay
there you go you decide if you want to
take that i'm talking i
have been thinking about this but i'm
not going to make a decision you know at
the first moment that you
you confront me with it fair enough um
that's so and i wouldn't
i wouldn't i would hope that no one
would actually that you you think on it
and
you know i've we've been sort of
enmeshed in this for a while now does
this hold stuff to you can i put this
yeah you can put those in there
i've never seen this object before um
that has been in my family
i swear this is at least 50 years old
it's probably brittle it's really
brittle
full of gpa unfortunately so what i was
going to say was okay so you just you
just did that you just took your first
prophylactic dose of of ivermectin
and you offered it to me as well and i
said you know i
i think i will and i'll report out next
week if if i did but um
upon being confronted with it in real
time with an audience
um you know i feel about it about like i
would if uh
if you had asked me to bear you in a
very public place no matter how i felt
it's like
that's not i'm gonna go someplace
private and think on this and make my
decision
where i know that i'm in full possession
of my faculties and
yeah and come back for the record i did
not do that
no no no nor would i have it's not my
style no not at all yeah
no um all right all right okay
well there it is um
cicadas yes right um so we just we
cicadas are happening this year right
everyone seems to know it's a brood x
here what does that mean and what is
going on with cicadas um people seem to
want
us to talk a little bit about cicadas
and it turns out we went to grad school
with two of the periodical cicada
experts and
they were experts the whole time the
cicadas were periodic
oh yeah they were not periodically
expert no i found both john and dave
this is
uh john cooley and dave marshall our
friends from grad school
um who uh yeah working on periodical
cicadas
with consistent expertise yeah exactly
there you go
um so here um zach if you would show
this
this map this is a current brood
distribution for periodical cicadas in
the mid-atlantic area so they do
continue on
off this map but this is this is a
decent one that i found and so
you know brood x that's just that's
because it's not describing species and
it's actually
only describing a temporal phenomenon
like when they emerge
um so it's not a subspecies either um
brood is the word that is being used and
they just got given
roman numerals and brood x we happen to
be in a brood x here and so that sounds
all
exciting and wonderful but i bet we
don't hear nearly as much about you know
brood xix you know and such um
so what you see are these overlapping
areas where
you know broods will emerge at um
for you know really just a concentrated
few weeks
reliably in particular years and if you
look boy it's going to be pretty small
for you guys but um brudex for instance
last emerged where it is
in 2004 it's emerging this year in 2021
and it's predicted to and i pretty much
guarantee that it will emerge again in
2038.
so what is that period so the the word
the term periodical cicadas refers to a
periodicity with which they
emerge so can i fill in a couple of
details here as to
where these critters are so that people
understand
okay what emerge means so what you have
is one of the few creatures on earth
that can rival human beings for the
length of its developmental period
for no particularly good reason it's not
like they have a lot to learn as kids
what they're doing is they're
underground attached
to the roots of trees getting nutrients
and then emerge means that their adult
form the final instar
comes into the world and is visible and
noisy as hell and very annoying
and um anyway so that's the phenomenon
in question it is this emergence
uh have you said how many years apart
you know that's what i was just about
getting to
go for it um so most of the broods
have a periodicity between them and you
can do the math yourself by looking at
this map
of 17 years and some of them
have a periodicity that is a time
between emergence of
13 years and then they're only out and
about as adults for a few weeks so they
spend the vast majority of their
lifetimes
you know underground as as brett said
eating and um and not being findable and
then they emerge
and you know what's up what's up with
those numbers
it's 17 years it's 13 years it's
it's never 14 years it's never 10 years
uh
it's never 18 years uh and you know
again
if this were a classroom we'd have asked
that at the beginning of the class and
you asked people to think on it and come
back to it and probably should have
started
off their brains overheated right come
back to the end and
um because we were so focused on their
stuff this year uh this year
this week forgot to do it um but i mean
the answer the answer appears to be
um that uh 17 and 13
the thing that they have in common is
that they are both prime
and that prime numbers are harder for
other animals with shorter uh
emergence times or lifespans or
developmental periods
to time their say migrations or
emergences to
such that if you have something with
like a two-year
cycle and it's going to come out every
two years
and some of those years it's going to be
able to find cicadas it might be able to
begin to to rely on that but not if
you've got a prime
number in terms of the periodicity
between emergencies
emergency well i i think that's that's
the other thing like we're going to talk
a little bit about for people who are in
the middle of one of these periodical
cigarette emergencies
it can feel like an emergency right like
it's i've actually so we've we've
experienced
cicadas in the neotropics um which we'll
talk about a little bit too
different species not periodical cicadas
they're just there
all the time they're just there making a
racket all the time
but it's not this kind of racket yeah
well it's pretty bad racket
tends to be loud when it's sunny but so
let's talk a little bit about why
selection would have done this i agree
the prime number thing is the place to
focus but in some sense
many things uh do something called
predator satiation
where basically if you imagine that
there's something out there that eats
another thing
the thing that gets eaten can partially
win
by not being available at all and then
suddenly being available in such large
numbers that the thing that eats them
has gotten to very low
population density because there isn't a
lot to eat and then suddenly there are
too many to eat
and so whatever it is that eats them
does the eating and
fills itself up and most of the
individuals are free from predation so
even within brute x
if they just spread themselves out if
they emerged over the course of the
spring and summer
in the place where they're currently
emerging uh you know there would
presumably be
crows and such there'd be lots of things
that would come in and basically make a
season out of it yeah
as opposed to it's going to be super
high numbers for a very short amount of
time
and the and it's this is not a group
selectionist argument right this is a
there's actually safety and numbers
argument that yes some of you will die
but more of you would have had you
spread out your emergence so
whereas you can be assured that there
will be predators on hand at uh you know
a brutex emergence
um fewer of you the members of brudex
cicada group are going to end up
succumbing to those predators if you all
come out at once
so let's fill in the details of who the
predators are likely to be here
they're almost certain to be birds right
and birds are going to have a very easy
time picking off cicadas because cicadas
are
dim oh so damn really dim
they're dim and they fly like they're
dim oh yeah and they sound when they
fly they sound like they're dim they
sound like they're short circuiting
yeah but um but in any case so imagine
if you were
birds and many birds are very smart you
know something
uh corbids or something like that crowds
uh you could imagine
a predator figuring out the pattern of
emergencies
right and moving and predicting
where the emergence was going to be and
that then the population of predators
could grow because it would be in the
right place every year
so the prime numbers thwart that
strategy
because you have to nail it exactly 17
years is a long
period and 17 years has to be hit
exactly if it were 16 years
then something that checked every eight
years or
16 years would nail it if it's 17 you
got to hit that
year number on the dot yeah so that's
right in any case
i think what we're really looking for
and it may be that
uh the ultimate explanation here i don't
know uh
john david you want to write to us and
tell us whether or not
passenger pigeons have anything to do
with this um but it may be that
passenger pigeons uh
you know were predators of these things
and that thwarting the passenger pigeons
from knowing where to show up
was um you know a useful strategy but i
like that like the brakes are off like
okay we can do a little arm waving
adaptive hypothesizing here because it's
cicadas and passenger pigeons we're
talking about the cicadas and passages
quite so careful
and we know who holds our feet to the
fire so that's right it's these guys so
actually just quickly show this is an
older paper exactly but this actually
they would have written this while we
were in grad school with them
um this is dave marshall and john cooley
reproductive character displacement and
speciation and periodical cicadas with
description of a new species
13-year majesticato neo-tradism and i'm
sure i'm
mispronouncing that but they basically
have septum desum you know 17 years
and uh trade us some 13 years yeah
anyway
the the point was if you uh emerge
in great abundance and you do so on a
prime number a long prime number
of years apart then a predator who tries
to figure out the pattern
and record it in its migrational pattern
is going to have a very confused
problem and actually now that i think
about it the fact of 13 and 7. if you
imagine some population that tries to
migrate the pattern
right uh the way that the pattern will
a population of a predator or cicadas
will clutter
itself by virtue of the fact that some
of these things are appearing every 13
years and some are appearing every 17
years it means that you don't quickly
get a repeating pattern
yeah first you go here then you go here
right right
yeah anyway it's all fascinating that's
really good
um so the actually john
cooley is on this paper as well i want
to read just a few paragraphs from this
2020 paper
uh called and zach you may show it
it's published in plos pathogens it's um
behavioral betrayal how select fungal
parasites enlist living insects to do
their bidding
it's a pretty great title i think you
know at least tickles
me so i want to read
just the first couple paragraphs under
what is active host
transmission make that a little bit
bigger insects under the explicit
control of parasitic fungi
and to entomopathogens are sometimes
characterized by colorful terms even
colloquially categorized as zombies
a moniker that draws comparison to both
fictitious and factual elements of
contemporary life
i also feel like this is the best
written scientific paper i've ever
read so you know kudos to you john and
the other authors on this
though the effects of entomo and tomopat
say i've never seen this word before
and tomopathogenic fungi on their hosts
are a far cry from behavior modifying
viruses such as rabies or the phantasmic
world of brain eating zombies that drag
their way through our popular culture
both rabies and select and
tomopathogenic fungi are nevertheless
archetypal examples of pathogens
that actively enlist their living hosts
for successful transmission
a phenomenon referred to hereafter is
active host transmission
and so we begin to see a connection
maybe to what we were talking about
earlier here
victims of the rabies virus experience
hydrophobia they refuse to swallow which
allows the virus to collect around their
mouths
and are much more likely to aggressively
bite and interact with others
this unsettling rewiring of animal
behavior supplants the interests of the
victim in favor of the interests of the
virus within
the phenomenon of parasite-induced
active oh
sorry what is it active host
transmission an animal host has evolved
numerous times across a variety of
taxonomic groups
for example toxoplasma gondii a protist
parasite
suppresses the fear response of rodents
and drives them to seek out feline foes
to help complete the life cycle of their
protist partner
horsehair worms pneumatomorpha encourage
their host crickets to drown themselves
which allows these parasites to complete
their own life cycle in water
likewise certain entomopathogenic fungi
such as masospora species manipulate
their host sexual behaviors to increase
their odds of transmission
such engagements appear to serve the
interests of the fungal pathogen over
the interests of their hosts
one more two more sentences here
manipulation of a host to focus on
pathogen transmission is fascinating
because it raises questions about the
nature of autonomy
and shines a light on the physical and
behavioral manifestations of parasitism
active host transmission is a form of
biological puppetry in which the
pathogen manipulates the behavior of its
powerless host
awesome awesome right um so not awesome
that this is happening no no
but um kind of amazing um so i'm gonna
try to find my notes since
zach if you would give that back to me
that would be terrific thank you
um it's going to be much easier now
this reminds me of cordyceps
which some number of people would be
familiar with because it's somehow
gotten
somewhat famous famous of late but
cordyceps is a
is a big genus it's a very specious
genus
of of uh fungi
which is actually i think maybe not
limited to the neotropics maybe i'm not
positive about that but it's very
widespread in the neotropics which is to
say the so-called
new world tropics new world um simply
being a
societal um description that um
europeans discovered it
last um and actually humans discovered
it last as well
um but it wasn't you know it wasn't it
wasn't new to the people who were
already living here
the point the europeans came but the
neo-tropics the new world tropics
have a ton of cordyceps and
the authors of this paper that i just
read um a piece of
distinguish between what's going on with
um
with active host uh transmission and
what's going on with cordyceps because
they say that usually cordyceps
the spores aren't spread until the host
is dead but
we've seen we've actually seen cicadas
in
neotropical jungles that are clearly
infected that have you know that
like that have the back end of them
they're all fungal
and what they're doing is they're acting
in very unusual ways they're climbing
and and you know this there is a name
for this called apparently summit
disease where you like you
you get infected with this thing and the
thing basically sends instructions to
your brain because you're a robot and
you're like a robot insect not a human
you're like a must climb must climb must
climb
and so they get to the top where um once
the spores are ready to spread they're
more likely to spread because you're at
the top of the canopy rather than
in the understory where it's relatively
still well
this actually solves a problem we were
thinking about uh so i
don't mean to short circuit the
discussion we don't have to but um
we were thinking about what to do um for
a thumbnail for this
and that's not responsive at all sort of
responsive we have from our last trip uh
to the amazon a very nice picture of an
insect that has been completely defeated
by cordyceps
and is just basically a fungal
ghost sitting on a leaf and also
somewhere we have pictures of these
cicadas that have this
uh this um growth off their back fungal
growth
yeah so anyway a that's interesting that
something one encounters with some
regularity if you know what you're
looking for
and yeah the idea of the manipulation of
hosts
is so powerful yeah going to encounter
rabies you might consider getting
vaccinated for yeah well i mean at least
when we got vaccinated against rabies it
was very hard
to um to get an extraordinary expensive
and um yeah um but yes you really really
don't want rabies no it's not a good
decision i mean
in fact i think there's one case in
which somebody has survived it
really i don't know there are any cases
i think believe there is one and it's
horrifying and
i probably should go back and figure out
what it is that
was done which may not even be
functional a person may have just gotten
lucky or been unusual in some
physiological way but
yeah it's usually entirely fatal if if
it gets to the point that you've
actually come down with the disease it's
obviously
not fatal if you've been bitten and you
immediately get treatment and the
treatment isn't as horrible as it once
yes yeah so i guess um you know i bring
up the
fungal pathogens thing in part because
we're just we're talking about pathogens
a lot today but also
uh for those of you who live within the
within the boundaries of brute x right
now and are being
driven crazy by them um just be grateful
that you're not infected by cortisones
right yeah i mean you could be grateful
for that no matter where you live but i
agree
i think so suffering through the
electronic
the cicadas yeah would be the right
thought indeed
um well we might finally be there after
a fairly chaotic episode i will uh
one thing i will say um before we end is
that um we had we had my mom here this
week and she actually
because she was flying out during our
live stream she actually just
just drove off so um she will be lis
this is the first
of our live streams that she has missed
since we've been doing this yeah and so
when you watch later mom
um we love you we love you jesse all
right uh so do we want to close out with
um
the usual the usual yeah so um
we'll be back next week same time same
place uh
but for those of you who are watching on
youtube and are interested in
asking a question or just hearing us
answer a lot of questions we will be
back in 15 minutes
to answer your super chat questions uh
we we
really actually enjoy them yeah and you
know we definitely get a little
little punch drunk and goofy by the end
because it's a long day but um
but we really do enjoy seeing the
diversity of questions that come across
the transom
at us consider joining my patreon
where we have the dark horse membership
which gives you access to a private
two-hour q a every month on the last
sunday of the month at 11 a.m pacific
and we just would leave that up too if
you can't join us live
um brett at his patreon has uh
larger ticket conversations that happen
on the first saturday and sunday of
every month before
our live streams um in the mornings
please if you have any ques logistical
questions not questions for a q a but
any logistical questions you have like
how do i ask a question
or you know when when is the private q a
um go ahead and email
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com and
maybe that's it again please subscribe
like share comment go to the clips
channel
yep and uh we'll be back in 15 minutes
in the meantime
eat good food be good to the ones you
love and get outside
be well everyone